[Music]
the conspirators never met to make their
plans in the open but in secret a few at
a time in each other's houses as was
natural many plans were proposed and set
in motion by them as they considered how
and when they should commit the awful
deed some propose to attach him while on
his way through the via sacra free often
walked there others at the time of the
comitia when he had to cross a certain
bridge to hold the election of
magistrates in the field before the city
they would Sultan fight their duties by
lot that some should Joss with him off
the bridge and the others should rush
upon him and slay him others proposed
that he be attacked when the
gladiatorial shows were held they were
near at hand for then because of these
contests no suspicion would be aroused
by the sight of men armed for the deed
the majority aged that he be killed
during the session of the Senate
for then he was likely to be alone there
was no admittance to non-members and
many of the Senators were conspirators
and carried swords under their togas
this plan was adopted fortune had a part
in this by causing Caesar himself to set
a certain day on which the members of
the Senate were to assemble to consider
certain motions which he wished to
introduce when the appointed day came
the conspirators assembled prepared in
all respects they met in the portico of
pompeius theater where they sometimes
gathered
[Music]
thus the divinity showed the vanity of
man's estate how very unstable it is and
subject to the vagaries of fortune for
Caesar was brought to the house of his
enemy there to lie a corpse before the
statue of one whom now dead he had
defeated when he was alive and fate
becomes a still stronger force if indeed
one acknowledges her part in these
things on that day his friends drawing
conclusions from certain auguries tried
to prevent him from going to the Senate
room as did also his physicians on
account of Vertigo's to which he was
sometimes subject and from which he was
at that time suffering and especially
his wife Calpurnia who was terrified by
a dream that night she clung to him and
said that she would not let him go out
on that day but Brutus one of the
conspirators though he was at that time
thought to be one of his most intimate
friends came up to him and said what do
you say Caesar are you going to pay any
attention to a woman's dreams and
foolish men's omens a man such as you
are you going to insult the Senate which
has honored you and which you yourself
convened by not going out if you take my
advice you will dismiss from your mind
the dreams of these people and go for
the Senate has been in session since
morning and is awaiting you he was
persuaded and went out meanwhile the
assassins were making ready
some of them stationed in themselves
beside his chair others in front of it
others behind it the augurs brought
forward the victims for him to make his
final sacrifice before his entry into
the Senate room it was manifest that the
omens were unfavorable the augurs
substituted one animal after another in
the attempt to secure a more auspicious
forecast finally they said that the
indications from the gods were
unfavorable and that there was plainly
some sort of curse
hiding in the victims in disgust Caesar
turned away toward the Setting Sun and
the augurs interpreted this action still
more unfavorably the assassins were on
hand and were pleased at all this
Caesars friends begged that he postpone
the present session on account of what
the soothsayers had said over his part
he was just giving the order to do this
but suddenly the attendants came to
summon him saying that the Senate had a
quorum
then Caesar cast a look towards his
friends and Brutus approached him again
and said come sir turn your back on
these people's nonsense and do not
postpone the business that deserves the
attention of Caesar and of the great
Empire but consider your own worth a
favorable omen
thus persuading him he at the same time
took him by the hand and led him in for
the Senate chamber was nearby Caesar
followed in silence when he came in and
the Senate saw him the members rose out
of respect to him
those who intended to lay hands on him
were all about him the first to come to
him was Julius Simba
whose brother Caesar had exiled and
stepping forward as though to make an
urgent appeal on behalf of his brother
he seized Caesars toga seeming to act
rather boldly for a suppliant and thus
prevented him from standing up and using
his hands if he so wished Caesar was
very angry but the men held to their
purpose and all suddenly bared their
daggers and rushed upon him first
Servilius Casca stabbed him on the left
shoulder a little above the collarbone
at which he had aimed but missed through
nervousness Caesar sprang up to defend
himself against him and Casca cooled to
his brother speaking in Greek in his
excitement the latter obeyed him and
drove his sword into Caesars side a
moment before cassie's had struck him
obliquely across the face Decimus Brutus
struck him through the thigh Casius long
Guinness was eager to give another
stroke but he missed and struck Marcus
Brutus on the hand manusia Stu made a
lunge at Caesar but he struck Rubeus on
the thigh it looked as if they were
fighting over Caesar he fell under many
wounds before the statue of Pompey and
there was not one of them but struck him
as he lay lifeless to show that each of
them had a share in the deed until he
received 35 wounds and breathed his last
the body of Cesar lay just where it
fella ignominiously stained with blood a
man who had advanced westward as far as
Britain and the ocean and who had
intended to advance Eastwood against the
realms of the Parthian x' and indi so
that with them also subdued an empire of
all land and sea might be brought unto
the power of a single head there he lay
no one daring to remain to remove the
body
[Music]
you
you
[Music]